hello you guys so today we're going to
do
a key for S4 Audi oky lost using this
kind of key slot
key it's
uh 10:09 I
guess um I think it's like
11 I'm not
sure anyway going to go to the outo
going be connected in the OBD having the
XP 400 ready for
us just going to go to
Audi and again the car is an Aly loss
[Music]
situation since it's an OST we're just
going to go to manual
selection we're going to go
A4 we're going to go from a to
16 press
yes we're going to go control unit
immobilizer
bcm2 so this is the thing we're going to
need to
do uh we're first going to go ahead
ahead and go and do read immobilizer
data um this is for the non-smart key
equipped which you're
working insert the
key it's an OSS so we're just going to
put the head
lamps and we're going to depr depress
the brake
pedal and then we're going to press okay
so make sure you do that you put
the hazard lights and the head head
lamps which in this
case it doesn't really seems to work for
me oh now it works so this is how you
put the headlamp so it's going to do
this beep and then you're just going to
press
okay and remember to press the brake
with your
feet so it tells us to turn off the
bcm2 it's going to go down on the
trunk going to peel up this
thing and the
vcm2 is this box right here so make sure
you take all the connections out uh one
by one so I'm just going to take the
connections out and I'll be back with
you so all of them are fairly easy to
take out so we're just going to take out
all of
them and we're going to go back to the
tool and we're just going to say
okay now we're going to need to power
off the BCM again we're going to go back
to
the trunk and connect all of them in the
same otor we did uh take them out so
give me a second okay so we have put
everything back
together going to go on the
car and you're going to press okay
and we're going to make sure to press
the brake
pedal so make sure in this time just
press your uh foot on the
brake and let it do its thingss and
don't forget to put the thing
on so we got all this
data
which going to help us uh create a
key uh down the
road just going to press
okay now we're going to make dealer key
so we're going to take the key put it in
the
slot we have the key
inside sorry for the annoying noise but
it's the light being
on so the dealer key was generated
successfully now we can go ahead and go
to key
learning we want to learn uh one number
of keys so we're going to hit
one I think we should put the key
already inside the ignition
[Music]
and I'm just going to press
okay so you heard the number one and it
had one of one was saying so key
learning process completed we're just
going to press
okay and we can remove the
key car started because I pressed it by
mistake but
we can just uh turn it
off and you can
see the remote is working and if we put
the key inside press the
brake car start right
away okay I think job is done
guys this is how you make an oy lust for
this
model